we've learned that China's chief
negotiator literally laughed in the face
of Donald Trump in the Oval Office
during recent trade talks that are going
on which of course as I'll show you
momentarily Donald Trump is claiming
we're just so extraordinarily successful
but let me sort of set it up for you and
then we'll get into the new details
Donald Trump campaigned on knowing all
about trade policy and he's going to fix
trade policy and it's going to be great
for them for the little guy and for
middle America and he's going to end
that trade imbalance with China and
everything's gonna be great and
everybody's just going to be winning big
lis Donald Trump instated some tariffs
it turns out that they actually caused
the opposite rather than reducing the
trade deficit the trade deficit has
increased to record levels Donald Trump
now is claiming on Twitter that maybe
he's not going to need more new tariffs
which were scheduled to be enacted on
March 1st because things are just going
so well in his conversations with China
he tweeted over the weekend quote I am
pleased to report that the US has made
substantial progress in our trade talks
with China on important structural
issues including intellectual property
protection technology transfer
agriculture services currency and method
many other issues as a result of these
very productive talks I will be delaying
the u.s. increase in tariffs now
scheduled for March 1 assuming both
sides make additional progress we will
be planning a summit for president xi
and myself at merrill mar-a-lago of
course to conclude an agreement a very
good weekend for the US and China so the
first question is did things actually go
well or is Trump realizing that the
tariffs he's already enacted are
disastrous for the United States and
he's trying to find a way out of
enacting further tariffs the answer to
that question is probably yes but let's
put that issue aside just for a second
and talk about what took place in the
Oval Office it turns out that Trump
exposed in these talks including a
briefly filmed piece of it that he
doesn't understand even the MOU
minor elements of how trade works and
was literally laughed at by a Chinese
negotiator who was in the room in the
Oval Office I'll set the stage for you
either before or after at some point of
the process of these trade discussions
they let cameras into the Oval Office
there's great officials there the
Chinese vice premier Liu hae is in there
the topic is trade agreements but Donald
Trump gets into this really weird
back-and-forth with Robert light Iser
who's the White House's top negotiator
and they start arguing about mo use an
MoU is a Memorandum of Understanding and
they start arguing over whether an MOU
is a real agreement or merely some kind
of like pre agreement agreement but you
still need the actual agreement later
you'll be able to tell from this video
I'm gonna play for you that Donald Trump
clearly thinks that the MOU is just a
sort of well we'll sort of agree to do
some stuff maybe in principle but Trump
doesn't really believe in MOU is worth
anything the reality is that mo use our
contracts Trump doesn't like the name
more than likely I'm guessing this is
because Donald Trump has had mo use
signed for real-estate deals and he
ended up getting screwed so he thinks
that it's the same thing in politics
that an MoU between two countries isn't
worth anything but it actually it is a
contract so what I'm gonna play for you
here is video of Donald Trump arguing
about this with his own top negotiator
Robert light Iser and Trump in the midst
of arguing with him it's just amazing
he's negotiating with the Chinese
but he's arguing with his own negotiator
over the semantic difference between an
MOU and a deal and an agreement and a
contract you have to sort of listen
carefully
but when light Iser explains to Trump
that he's wrong that mo use our
contracts you hear a laugh in the
background and everybody in the room has
said that that was the China Chinese
vice premier Liu hey who can't believe
what's going on
I think the MOU is gonna be very short
term
we expect to go into I don't like mo use
because they don't mean anything to me
that I mean anything I think you thought
of just going into a document
I was never never a fan of an MOU people
refer to it like interviews it's not a
compete it's an actual contract between
the two parties do a Memorandum of
Understanding agreement between coverage
everything in great detail
let's just call them a memorandum at
ursday that's a legal term it's a
contract contracts laughs while they
last there's no term they laughs while
they last by the way I disagree I think
that a memorandum of understanding it's
not a contract to the extent that we
want so you hear that laughter in the
background which again was the Chinese
Vice Premier who's there to participate
in these negotiations can you imagine
coming to the Oval Office all the way
from China to try to avert more tariffs
which are just mutually damaging to the
US and to China and Donald Trump is
having a semantic disagreement with his
top negotiator in front of cameras but
not one that is even particularly
relevant
he just doesn't agree with the name of
what these agreements are his top
negotiator says this this is not just
like a general term sheet
these are agreements these are contracts
these are binding a period and even
after this Trump just continues for
another minute harping on this semantic
disagreement we're doing a memorandum of
understanding that will be put into a
final contract I assume but to me the
final contract is really the thing Bob
but I think you mean that two is really
the thing that means something a
Memorandum of Understanding is exactly
that it's a Memorandum of what our
understanding is but to me the contract
is the real question is about so we do a
memorandum of understanding which
frankly you can do or not do I don't
care if you do it or not to me it
doesn't mean very much but if you do a
memorandum how long will it take to put
that into a final binding contract what
trade agreements all right there right
no we'll never use it you're going to
have the state document it's going to be
called a traitor we're never going to
use MOU again are they going to put that
into another again we have two major
hurdles I don't want to put the cart
before assuming you decide whether the
agreement it'll be signed by the two
people it'll be a trainee game of the I
like that much better I like that term
much with that I wouldn't go into a
memorandum in to a trade agreement
either you gonna make a deal to get not
to have these other agreements I mean
that would be because they're not that
meaningful in my opinion but in a way I
like that much better this is this is
unbelievable oh this is notable for a
bunch of different reasons first of all
Trump just doesn't get it okay it was
explained to him multiple times in this
video that the MOU is a binding contract
and he insists that it's not he keeps
saying either we're gonna do a deal or
we're not I don't care about em OU's but
his chief negotiator you can see how the
propagandizing of all of this stuff
works and how Trump ends up thinking
that he's right and that he's smarter
because Trump is holding up in an
embarrassing way the entire substantive
discussion about what will the agreement
say are we terrifying or not right
those are the relevant questions Trump
is holding up the entire thing over his
understanding of what's the difference
between an MOU and whatever else
his chief negotiator clearly just to
placate Trump not because Trump's right
because he sees that it's becoming a
huge distraction says hey you know what
we're not going to call it an MOU we're
literally gonna have the exact same
document but we're gonna change the
title to a trade agreement this doesn't
substantively change anything it merely
placates Trump but then Trump actually
thinks he made a good point we
knew this was happening behind the
scenes Pat we would learn about how
behind the scenes staffers are endlessly
frustrated with how Trump just doesn't
understand stuff and they have to dumb
things down or appear to acquiesce when
in reality we're talking about semantics
and a 70 something year old man who just
doesn't get it we just saw what normally
happens behind the scenes which is
increasingly frustrated adults in the
room go this guy doesn't get it you want
us to call it an agreement instead of an
MoU they're just crossing out the name
and naming it something else but it's
the exact same thing yeah for us the
veil has been totally lifted the guy
claimed to be a master negotiator we now
know that not to be true he claimed to
be a master when it comes to trade
policy we also know that that's not true
when he doesn't know what the hell he's
talking about there but for his base of
supporters who watch that video and see
that Wow Trump persuaded people in the
room to no longer call that piece and
MOU it's called something else now they
view that as a victory and this is the
type of thing that later Trump will tell
if we didn't have video of this okay
this is one of those things where Trump
will go to a rally and he'll have
written into his speech how he came in
and forced a deal rather than just an
MOU if we didn't have video that
minute-and-a-half
becomes at a rally Trump saying listen
they came in the Chinese came in and my
negotiators came in and if it weren't
for me they would have come out of this
thing with just an MOU and it wouldn't
have gone anywhere but I went in there
and I negotiated because I'm a good
negotiator and I said we're not doing an
MOU we're doing an agreement and we're
getting it done and it's going to be
mined by binding and then his Magha
hat-wearing crowd all starts cheering we
now have the video of this and we saw it
was a really dumb semantic disagreement
which led to people who understand stuff
realizing this guy's [ __ ] if he wants
us to change the name of the document
we'll change the name that would be a
minute and a half to two minutes at a
speech of Donald Trump claiming some
kind of big art of the deal negotiation
victory the only other thing I want to
say about this understand now that in
the same way that the adults in the room
are conceding here and saying we'll call
it whatever the hell this guy wants
because we've just got to move on and
talk about the substance this probably
leads to a lot of people acquiescing to
trump stupid demands because he just
doesn't get what is even being discussed
and in order to move things along my
guess is this type of thing where
everybody says oh my god look just call
it whatever the hell he wants so we can
move on it's probably happening all the
time and in some cases it's probably
more action ibly significant materially
significant than this particular example
this reminds me this allows me to
preview by the way we are planning an
upcoming segment on an issue in the
United States which is an issue of
culture it's an issue of politics it's
an issue of economics and class and a
lot of different things the growing
intellectual divide in the United States
of America this is a real thing this
video is a great opportunity for me to
mention that that's something that we're
working on and we'll have that coming up
for you at some point very very soon
let's take a break make sure to give us
a like on Facebook at facebook.com slash
David Pakman show
plenty more to discuss